[Applause]
spirit building how prophetic we now
know England players Raheem Sterling and
Joe Gomez having joined the national
squad continued their altercation
resulting in sterling being left out of
the team after allegedly trying to grab
Gomez by the throat we're in a sport
where emotions often run high I think
him in his post last night explained
that for a very brief moment his
emotions ran over and it would be
correct to say that's not the same for
Joe and these things happen in football
both players have been training with the
squad prior to Thursday's game against
Montenegro Raheem Sterling won't be in
the side but he's patched things up with
his teammate saying on social media both
Joe and I have had words and figured
things out and moved on EMA Heskey
played 62 times for England he believes
keeping Raheem Sterling with the squad
is the right decision he's a huge
influence on everyone else as long as
he's in the right frame of mind
obviously something's happened he's he's
owned up to it and he's he's trying to
move up anyone who watched Sunday's
match heard Raheem Sterling being
relentlessly booed by the fans who used
to cheer him
[Music]
as former team mates made life difficult
on the pitch
[Applause]
here at least very few so football has
just again daily bonus games